what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel
richard on data and if this is your
first time here my name is richard
and this is a channel where i help you
break into data science and grow your
skills in the field
so this is going to be another video in
my our tutorial series
and specifically it's the fourth and
final video in my series all about using
the carrot package for machine learning
so in the last video in this tutorial
series we covered things like how do you
interpret confusion matrix output
how do you tune the hyper parameters so
you can do this through using either the
tune length or tuned grid arguments
and then how do you deal with the class
imbalance issue because
the data set that i'm working here is a
70 to 30 split
in the real world plenty of data sets
are a lot worse than that
so we covered up sampling and down
sampling
and the first thing i'm going to cover
here is another method that
i think in a lot of cases works really
well for dealing with these kinds of
problems
so before we get into this subscribe to
my channel if you haven't already and
smash the like button for the youtube
algorithm
and then if you guys would be willing to
support my channel i'll have links in
the description of the video to
my paypal account my patreon account and
to my crypto wallet addresses
also as always this script will be
available on my github repo
so where we left off last time was we
had just used up sampling and the
training process for our random forest
we created the confusion matrix and the
results from this
well for down sampling too are pretty
interesting
because if you remember right from the
beginning we actually had higher
accuracy than this
but we had a bigger discrepancy between
sensitivity and specificity
it was closer to like a sensitivity of
87
with a specificity that was like in the
20s and 30s
and so in a lot of real world
circumstances
i am personally okay with having lower
overall accuracy
if it means that there's a bit better of
a balance between sensitivity and
specificity
again your case your individual
circumstances might vary
but in a lot of just real world
scenarios i've personally run into
if you've got a specificity that's way
down in the 20s and 30s
that's really problematic now this one
isn't particularly
amazing necessarily either but in my
book this is a massive improvement
now we're going to go over another way
that we can kind of
uh correct for the class imbalance issue
and that's going to be altering the
boundaries for classifier thresholds
so when we train a random forest or
other classifier
what's going on on the back end is it's
assigning every observation
a probability of belonging to each of
the different classes
so in our example here when we're
working with the german credit data set
there are two classes remember there's
the bad credit and there's the good
credit
well if the classifier assigns a
probability to an observation
of greater than 0.5 of belonging to the
bad class
it's going to classify that observation
as belonging to the bad
class now that's a pretty stringent
assumption
particularly when we have imbalanced
data like this where only
30 percent of observations belong to the
bad class in the first place
so we can tweak this assumption instead
of
a 0.5 uh threshold we can change to 0.5
to like
0.333 for instance so here's what we're
going to do
let's use the predict function i'm going
to use the rf
tl classifier that i created earlier
now i didn't do a whole lot of tweaking
to this i just played around with the
tune length argument
to train that way to length was
specified
i think it was 10 at the time so there
was 10 different values
of the m tri hyper parameter that i was
looking over
then test set is where our actual data
is coming from and we're going to
specify
type equals prob here now this fitted
prob
object here is a data frame and if we
look down here in the console at what
this
actually looks like what it's got is for
the various observations
there's a probability of belonging to
the bad class for instance here it's
0.52
probability of belonging to the good
class is 0.48
so this particular observation here was
just classified as the bad class
so what we're going to do here is just
manually change this
i'm going to create a new uh object
called altered probe that's just a
vector where i'm isolating the bad
uh column from this fitted probe data
frame
now what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to assign this to
bad if this probability is greater than
.333
and to good otherwise so now that we've
created that let's just run the
confusion matrix the same way that we
would before and let's see how well we
did
so we're actually going further down
this approach of we're having less
accuracy overall but we're having a
better balance between sensitivity and
specificity
now we have a sensitivity of 0.657
specificity is 0.5778
and the positive predictive value is
0.7841
so for these first three things that i
look at right off the bat
all of them for the first time uh this
exercise here
are greater than 0.5 so i think that
that's good
now your individual situation will vary
it depends on what the specific measure
of success is for you
but once again for me the majority of
the time
i like taking a decrease overall in
accuracy
if it means i have a better balance
between sensitivity and specificity
but that's just me so one final related
topic that we're going to cover before
moving on to the next thing
is actually plotting an roc curve
so with an roc curve we're going to have
sensitivity on one axis
and then one minus specificity on the
other axis
so we can see as we change that
threshold
kind of like how we just did in that
example how do sensitivity and
specificity move
and so we're going to use this rocr
package to do this there are multiple
different ways that you can go about
doing this
particularly there's there's one option
where you can just
use a geom roc function to just tap this
onto a ggplot object
but this rocr package is one that i've
been working with myself for a little
while that i happen to like myself
so to set this up we're going to create
two objects they're going to be called
predictions
and labels now the thing is this is true
of caret functions it's true of tidy
models
and it's true of this next prediction
function that we're going to use
they have each different ways of
figuring out what's the positive class
and what's the negative class
so you may have to just do some trial
and error with this a little bit
all of them have their own default ways
but it may just be easier to just go
about it by trial and error
take a look at the roc curve that comes
out and make sure that it you know
matches reality because you'll know if
you have the the wrong class specified
but in this case we're going to specify
the uh
good probabilities here and
we're going to create this pred object
based on the prediction function
so we're just creating this prediction
uh object based on the predictions and
labels that we've already specified
so it tells us it's a prediction
instance with 300 data points
and then basically in the next thing
that we're going to define
using this performance function this is
essentially just
just specifying what performance metrics
that we actually want to visualize
so if you go to the help documentation
for this performance function
it lists out all the different objects
you have it's a very flexible function
but here i'm going to specify the true
positive rate
that's sensitivity and the false
positive rate
that's just one minus specificity
so we're going to do that we're going to
basically average over the various
thresholds
specify colorize equals true so we get
a pretty set of colors for the graph
and bam we have our roc curve so
one thing you'll know that you specified
the wrong class
like here if i'd specified fitted prob
uh dollar sign bad
here the this curve would have been
under this diagonal line going from
0 to 1. we see it's above that
line here so that means we have the
correct roc curve here
so there you go it's good looking uh if
you had an absolutely perfect classifier
it would basically be at a right angle
zero going up to one over here and then
cutting over here but
uh because we're not working with
academic data you're
probably never going to see that kind of
thing all right and now the final thing
that we're going to cover in this
tutorial series on carrots
is going to be training and resampling
and ensembling over multiple models
so in this whole tutorial series thus
far we've only been working with the
random forest classifier
now we're going to recreate one of those
but we're also at the exact same time
going to
try two different methods those are the
elastic
net that's specified by the met by uh
glm net for the method and we're also
going to try support vector machines
with a radial kernel
that's specified by the svm radial
method
and we're going to use this carrot list
functionality from the carrot ensemble
package
now there is actually built-in
functionality in carrot
uh for doing this kind of resampling
approach
but this carrot ensemble approach is
newer
so we're just gonna go with that here so
we have to specify the training control
up front like we always do
and now for now don't worry about the
tuning length and the tuning grid
because we're going to deal with that
later
inside here it's mostly going to be the
same for the resampling method i'm going
to specify
repeated cross validation one thing that
is going to be different here is
you want to specify something to this
index argument
now essentially because we're training
multiple different models here we want
to make sure the resampling indices
are the same for the random forest as
for the elastic
net as for the support vector machine
methods and so
if i didn't specify anything here for
index
carrot is usually going to be smart
enough and figure it out
but you want to be as safe as possible
for here i'm just going to use this
create folds
uh function here to do five-fold
repeated cross-validation
and we're gonna go from there so
everything else is gonna be mostly the
same
i'm gonna keep today uh i'm gonna use
the down sampling
method that we were discussing earlier
because that had fairly reasonable
results
and now in terms of specifying the
actual methods to use
there's a couple different approaches
and i'm going to show you both of them
the simpler one is just to specify a
method list
that would just be rf for random forest
glm net for elastic net and svm radio
and then you're done
alternatively if you want to get a
little bit more specific about it
and start playing around with the tuning
length and the tuning grid
inside of this carrot list function
which is totally analogous to the train
function we were using before
to tune list you can pass to a
named list so we need uh named
objects inside of it i'm just keeping it
simple calling them rf
glnet and svm and then you use this
additional
carrot model uh spec for specification
a function here specifying that we want
to use the
for example rf method with a tuning
length of 10
or svm with you know method is svm radio
with a tuning length of five
however you want to customize it so
uh we're going to just keep to the more
customized approach here with the
with the tune list instead of letting
carrot figure it out automatically
and then we're going to use this
resamples function
to see how well we did we create this
ensemble
the carrot list function just trains
these three different approaches
and then remember before we specified
the two class summary for our summary
function
that means we're going to get outputs
for roc
for sensitivity and for specificity
and we're going to see how well we did
so we got a lot of output from each of
the different iterations of these the
of these things running which is
actually only only five free samples
here
uh but what we end up with here is you
can compare for instance the median and
mean
roc and we see uh the random forest
seems to be doing better than the
elastic net or the support vector
machines
i mean it's pretty close but
on average it seems to be doing better
so
uh yeah that that tells me a lot when i
start
moving on from my training data and you
know want to actually summarize the
results on the testing set
all right so that concludes this series
on machine learning using the carrot
package
and now i don't want to say that we just
scratched the surface
because there were four parts to this uh
to this tutorial
but there's a lot more to the carrot
package
that i haven't even gone into in this
series
so if you read the github documentation
written by its author
max kuhn you can go into a lot more
greater detail
and hey if you plan to use the carrot
package all the time
i do strongly recommend going through
that documentation
at least taking a skin through it and
just learning all the different things
that you can do
using carrot carrot is not the only way
that you can do machine learning
an r there is the newer tidy models
series of packages which i'm going to do
a series over all that
uh in the near future now at the time
i'm recording this particular video
anyway
carrot is significantly more mature but
hey who knows that may not be the case
several months from now a couple years
from now
so who knows ebay though i can pretty
much guarantee
if you have a practical use case for
machine learning
you're going to find it really easy to
easy to do
using carrot so i'm going to leave you
all there
thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it consider
sharing it smash the like button if you
haven't already
and then i will see you all in the not
so distant future
until then richard on data